Let's make some cottage pie
and let's talk through a few things I can do better next time.
First I started with peeling and chopping my potatoes,
and then I added water and salt and put them on the boil.
Once fork tender, I drained them
and then I added butter, sour cream,
and milk. Here was my first mistake,
as the potatoes ended up crumbly from not enough dairy.
I should have used more sour cream,
some cream cheese if I had any,
and cream instead of milk.
I set them aside while I browned my beef.
I would have added onion if I had some.
I added chopped carrots because I didn't have vegetable medley,
and then I added a half cup of flour,
but I needed a three quarter cup.
Actually added a quart of homemade bone broth,
Worcestershire sauce, onion powder and garlic powder,
and salt and pepper.
I poured the mixture into my 9 by 13,
and then I added a quart of canned green beans at the end
so they wouldn't get soggy.
I then topped with my crumbly mashed potatoes,
molding it together with my hands,
and then I put it in the oven at 3:50 for 45 minutes.
I did add a tray underneath to catch the mess of it spilled over,
which it did. Overall it was really good,
it just needs a few adjustments next time. Recipe in the caption.